>>> A SYMBOL MOVE FROM RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
VISITING THE BRIDGE LINKING
RUSSIAN ANNEXED CRIMEA TO THE
RUSSIAN MAIN LAND.
THIS IS THE SAME BRIDGE THAT WAS
HIT BY A TRUCK BOMB BACK IN
OCTOBER.
CNN'S WILL RIPLEY IS LIVE IN
KYIV FOR US.
WILL, WHAT MORE ARE YOU HEARING
ABOUT THIS AS RUSSIAN HAS
LAUNCHED A NEW BARRAGE OF
STRIKES ON UKRAINIAN POWER
FACILITIES?
>> Reporter: KATE, THE TIMING
NOT A COINCIDENCE TO HAVE
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA SHOWING
VLADIMIR PUTIN DRIVING ACROSS
THE KURDISH BRIDGE WHAT CH WAS
BADLY DAMAGED AND THERE WERE
MORE THAN 70 RUSSIAN MISSILES
LAUNCHED FROM THE REGION OF
RUSSIAN, THOSE MISSILES INTENDED
TO DEBILITATE THE POWER GRID IN
UKRAINE AND THERE WAS VERY, VERY
LIMITED SUCCESS IN TERMS OF THIS
OPERATION.
THE UKRAINIAN AIR FORCE SAID
THEY INTERCEPTED MORE THAN 60 OF
THE MISSILES THAT WERE LAUNCHED.
SOME OF THEM DID HIT THEIR
TARGETS, HOWEVER, THIS HAS
RESULT FLD TOTAL BLACKOUTS, LOTS
OF ELECTRICITY IN TWO UKRAINIAN
CITIES BUT POWER INTERRUPTIONS
HERE IN THE SOUTH.
THIS COMES AT A TIME THAT U.S.
INTELLIGENCE HAS BEEN SAYING
THAT FIGHTING IS GOING TO SLOW
DOWN DURING THE WINTER MONTHS.
THE TEMPERATURES ARE PLUMMETING.
IT IS NOT A GOOD TIME TO BE
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY.
BUT THERE IS STILL FIGHTING
HAPPENED IN DONETSK WITH RUSSIAN
TROOPS TRYING TO MAKE AN ADVANCE
TOWARD THE WEST WILBUT BEING HE
OFF BY THE UKRAINIANS.
SO WE'LL HAVE TO SEE IF THE
FIGHTING DOES SLOW DOWN.
CERTAINLY THE RUSSIAN MISSILE
TRIKES HAVE REALLY REVVED UP THE
SITUATION ONCE AGAIN.
THEY WERE ANTICIPATED BY THE
UKRAINIANSS WHO SAY IT IS TIME
NOW FOR THE UNITED STATES TO
MAKE A DECISION ON THOSE PATRIOT
MISSILE DEFENSE SYSTEMS THEY
BADLY NEED.
>> THANKS.
IT IS GREAT TO HAVE YOU THERE.
>>> JOINING ME NOW, JILL
DOUGHERTY, A FORMER CNN MOSCOW
CHIEF.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WHAT MESSAGE IS THERE TO SEE IN
THIS?
>> KATE, AS SOON AS I HEARD THAT
HE DID THAT, I WENT BACK TO
2000.
AND IF YOU REMEMBER, DURING THAT
PERIOD, RIGHT BEFORE I WAS
ELECTED FOR THE FIRST TIME, HE
FLEW A PLANE, A FIGHTER JET INTO
CHECHNYA.
SO THIS IS CLASSIC PUT IN.
I'M STRONG, I'M OUT THERE.
THIS IS OUT BRIDGE.
WE'RE BACK IN OPERATION.
AND REMEMBER, THIS REALLY, THIS
IS HIS BRIDGE.
HE MEAN, HE GOT THE MONEY FOR
IT, HE GAVE THE ORDER TO BUILD
IT.
IT IS VERY, VERY PERSONAL.
AND JUST LOOK AT THAT VIDEO.
HE'S LITERALLY AT THE WHEEL, I
BELIEVE OF A MERCEDES, BUT AT
LEAST A BIG CAR, DRIVING ACROSS.
SO SYMBOLIC AND, YOU KNOW, I
THINK IT IS A SIGN THAT HE'S
DIGGING IN HIS HEELS AND THIS
WAR IS GOING TO GO ON.
>> AND ALSO POTENTIALLY A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF SYMBOLISM IN
TWO AIR BASES DEEPER IN THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE TWO AIR BASES
THAT ARE DEEPER WITHIN RUSSIA
BEING HIT WITH EXPLOSIONS.
NO ONE CLAIMING RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE BLAST, JILL, BUT THE
RUSSIANS ARE TALKING ABOUT IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS COULD
MEAN?
>> YEAH, IT IS A LITTLE UNCLEAR.
BUT IF IT IS THE UKRAINIANS, AND
THE UKRAINIANS USUALLY, IN CASES
LIKE THIS, ACTUALLY THERE
HAVEN'T BEEN MANY CASES LIKE
THIS, THIS IS SERIOUS.
THIS IS INSIDE RUSSIA.
BUT THEY USUALLY GLOAT OR MOCK
BUT DON'T TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
SO IF IT IS TRUE, THEY ARE NOW
EXPANDING THE WAR AS THEY HAVE
BEEN INCREMENTALLY INTO RUSSIA.
AND AGAIN ANOTHER SIGN THAT THIS
WAR IS GOING TO CONTINUE AND
PROBABLY ESCALATOR AT LEAST MOVE
EAST.
>> ONE PART ABOUT ONE ASPECT OF
ALL OF THIS, IS PUTIN'S ABILITY
TO CONTINUE FUNDING HIS WAR AND
WE LEARNED THAT UNITED STATES
AND WESTERN ALLIES HAVE AGREED
TO IMPOSE A PRICE CAP ON RUSSIAN
OIL SAYING THEY WON'T PAY MORE
THAN $60 PER BARREL.
RUSSIA IS REJECTING THE PRICE
CAP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS DOES?
>> IT IS A NEW TACTIC AND NOBODY
REALLY KNOWS EXACTLY HOW IT IS
GOING TO WORK.
BUT THE IDEA IS, YOU DO TWO
THINGS.
YOU CAP THE MONEY THAT RUSSIA
MAKES ON OIL SO THEY GET LESS
MONEY TO SPEND ON THE CAR.
THAT IS THE THEORY.
BUT AT SAME TIME, YOU DON'T HURT
THE MARKET.
SO THAT CONSUMERS DON'T HAVE TO
PAY VERY HIGH ENERGY PRICES.
WHETHER THAT WILL WORK THE WAY
THEY THINK IT WILL, IT IS A
QUESTION.
THEY THINK IT WILL.
BUT ULTIMATELY IT COULD HURT
RUSSIA'S ABILITY TO HAVE MORE
FUNDING TO FIGHT THE WAR.
AT LEAST THAT IS THE IDEA.
>> THAT IS THE IDEA.
THOUGH, AS UKRAINE SAID, THEY
NEED THE WAR TO END NOW, NOT
LATER AS THIS PRICE CAP TRICKLES
IN AND GETS INTO EFFECT.
IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU, JILL.
THANK YOU.